when county has a posse of 17 new
sheriff's deputies all of them less than
a year old this photo shows more than a
dozen members of the same Sheriff's
Department posing with their babies all
born this year their dads worked for the
Jefferson County Sheriff's Office just
south of st. Louis Missouri Meg Oliver
is here with the story of how this
County's baby boom was born good morning
Anthony good morning a bundle of joy can
bring parents together but with this
Sheriff's Department welcoming 17
newborns they might need to call in
reinforcements you have to wonder if
something is in the water in Jefferson
County 17 infants within 1 Sheriff's
Department born in the same year I think
no one realized how many babies there
were until we showed up that day for the
picture and then it was a kind of an all
factor just seeing them all meet Conner
the first child born on January 10th
then last month little Micah and Kade
became number 16 and 17 born only hours
apart
turns out this baby boo may be thanks to
a financial boon for the counties
deputies it was a huge help obviously
having kids is expensive the theory is
the babies all came from a proposition
but maybe not the kind you're thinking
in April of 2018 Jefferson County
residents voted to pass proposition P a
property tax increase that raise
salaries in the sheriff's office
something these officers haven't seen
for over 30 years when you go from 37
38,000 starting pay to 50,000 that's
life-changing for a family I think
property definitely helped more
flexibility and starting a family when
there's more money come in the prop P
babies as they're known have some steep
competition around the country from nine
babies at the Rancho Cucamonga Fire
Department the nine labor and delivery
nurses at the Maine Medical Center and
the 36 nurses from the Kansas City
Children's Hospital all having babies so
far in 2019 Jefferson County can boast
to have one of the largest booms at one
time with their 17 bun
of joy and now these 17 families have
something else to feel fortunate about
each other there's a lot of parenting
tips going around the office right now
um so we're always joking and asking how
how each other's children are doing and
you see one of the guys coming in
looking pretty tired and you're not sure
if they were on a call all night or if
they were up with their their newborn
all night it's a good tired right all
moms and their babies are happy and
healthy and surprisingly no names were
repeated opposition he was passed in
hopes to prevent the officers from
leaving for more competitive salaries
and as a result Jefferson County might
have several prop P recruits one day
that's good for the count nobody in that
Sheriff's Department can complain about
not getting enough sleep because it
sounds like nobody probably is
absolutely adorable I'm also thinking
they must have a low crime rate in
Jefferson's gonna make them better
sheriffs as well yes you've been pulled
over by you know for driving while
parenting and reaching for items in the
backseat you know officer you understand
and then of course they will they do now
they will all right thank you very much